again tonight with my monologue so today
president Trump pled not guilty to all
37 felony charges at a federal
courthouse in Miami make no mistake the
Department of Justice they're pretty
much taking a wrecking ball to our Great
American Republic and our constitution
along with it half of the country has
now lost faith in the rule of law this
is now the third election presidential
election cycle in a row with the FBI and
the doj are throwing cinder blocks on
the scales of that presidential race
first in 2016 they gave Hillary Clinton
a free pass we know James Comey told us
she mishandled top secret material
destroyed the evidence she acid washed
hard drive servers with bleach pit
destroying cell phones blackberries with
hammers and of course the media mob they
didn't care of course Comey he didn't
care now they're accusing us about what
about ISM their new favorite word what
about ISM listen
the real issue on the political side is
Republicans are going to be able to play
the what about ISM game and say C Joe
Biden did it too uh any charges against
Donald Trump are going to be purely
political is this kind of political what
about ISM from Jim Jordan playing
actually going to resonate that he's
trying to play right now what about ism
is uh very intense right now and you are
somebody who definitely knows facts on
this case
how cute the left-wing media found a new
word uh what about ISM
um maybe another term that they can uh
replace it with would be equal justice
under the law an equal application of
our laws and the lack thereof in America
today let's use Comey and his own words
no reasonable prosecutor whatever
prosecutor charge Hillary Clinton
despite her serious misconduct pay close
attention top secret classified material
she shouldn't have had and that does not
include the 33 000 deleted emails
from the group of
females
Department
110 emails in 52 email chains have been
determined by the owning agency to
contain classified information at the
time they were sent or received
eight of those chains contained
information that was Top Secret at the
time they were sent 36 of those chains
contained secret information at the time
and eight contained confidential
information at the time although there
is evidence of potential violations of
the statutes regarding the handling of
classified information
our judgment is that no reasonable
prosecutor would bring such a case
okay what about ISM at the very same
time in 2016 when Clinton got a free
pass the FBI was propagating their own
Russia hoax the same month as a matter
of fact that's the dirty conspiracy
theory developed by the Clinton campaign
abort bought and paid for dirty Russian
misinformation dossier to smear Donald
Trump before the election and the media
mobbed the Democrats the FBI they all
lied to you the American people and that
lie was perpetrated for over three years
no consequences at all whatsoever not an
apology not in a correction from the
corrupt media mob and in 2020 it
happened again the FBI covered up the
very real Hunter Biden laptop Scandal
remember they pre-bunked it even though
they had it in December of 2019 meeting
with big Tech in the lead-up to the 2020
race weekly with big Tech suggesting
they may be victims of Russian
disinformation in reality they knew it
wasn't Russian disinformation they had
possession of the laptop they knew Rudy
Giuliani the president's attorney would
likely leak it so hence the pre-bunking
and according to John Solomon he
verified that his contents were in fact
known by the FBI that the complete
authent uh authenticity they
authenticated it at the FBI at the very
same time former FBI officials continues
to suggest that Trump was colluding with
Russia what we know now the Durham
report a complete and total farce an
investigation that never should have
begun and now in 2023 is this more
election interference from our Very Own
federal government here's the doj with
the FBI striking once again stacking 37
charges against Donald Trump including
violations of the Espionage Act for
allegedly mishandling classified
material while giving Biden just like
Hillary a free pass for also allegedly
mishandling classified material even
worse the FBI is trying its best to hide
evidence of corruption against the
current president now this is the big
news that everyone needs to pay
attention to now first the bureau
seemingly denied the existence of that
1023 document that Senator Grassley and
James Comer were requesting from the FBI
and Christopher Wray which recorded
serious allegations of bribery against
Joe Biden made by what was a trusted and
paid for FBI informant then director Ray
refused to comply with the house
subpoena demanding a copy of the 1023
document until Cromer chairman Comer was
on the verge of holding Ray in contempt
now we just found out that the 1023
document ultimately produced to Congress
it had redactions covering up very
pertinent important information and
here's Iowa Senator Chuck Grassley
describing that information
10 23 produced
to the house committee's redacted
reference
that the foreign National who allegedly
bribed Joe and Hunter Biden allegedly
has audio recordings of his conversation
with them
17.
such recordings
according to the 1023 the foreign
National possesses 15 audio recordings
of phone calls between him and Hunter
Biden
according to the 10 23
the foreign National possesses two audio
recordings of phone calls between him
and then Vice President Joe Biden
these recordings were allegedly kept as
a sort of insurance policy for the
foreign National in case that he got
into a tight spot
now former acting attorney general Matt
Whittaker who will join us in a moment
said these tapes could be cataclysmic a
cataclysmic event for Joe Biden but it
almost seems like the FBI doesn't want
to be investigated I wonder why now keep
in mind they have had this 1023 form for
at least three years so is Senator
Grassley correct did a barista executive
does he have 17 recorded tapes 15 of
Hunter two of Joe Biden then his vice
president that he kept as an insurance
policy is the FBI in possession of these
recordings or will they continue to
shield and protect Joe and Hunter Biden
ahead of another election all while
Prosecuting Donald Trump to the fullest
extent of the law now today on Capitol
Hill the FBI deputy director didn't have
a lot of answers take a look
deputy director abadi is it true that
the FBI has a report making those
allegations
I'm not going to comment on that Senator
and why is that
I'm just not going to comment on
information we received investigations
your own obligation to the American
people to be candid about evidence of
corruption by the president of the
United States
this is uh an area that I'm not going to
get into with you Senator well I
understand you don't want to and that's
why people are mad at the FBI because
you're stonewalling and covering up
serious allegations of evidence of
corruption from the president multiple
courts have uncovered extraordinary
abuses perpetrated by your agency you
are at the same time concealing
information
about serious allegations made against
the president of the United States even
as your institution also targets his
chief political opponent in an
unprecedented way
can they not see how bad this looked do
they not see the double standard or do
they just not care at this point I'm
believing they don't care right now the
only people seriously investigating Joe
Biden are members of Congress that's
Comer's committee and Jim Jordan's
committee now this week chairman Comer
issued a new subpoena for Hunter's
Barista business partner Devin Archer
pictured right here playing golf with
the big guy himself Joe Biden keep in
mind Hunter's cushy job on that board of
barisma with the Devin Archer is the
focus of these very claims against the
Vice President in that 1023 form so
don't be distracted by any insignificant
forthcoming gun or tax charges that we
hear might be imminent against Hunter
Biden that's only the low-hanging fruit
the real issue is being investigated in
both the house oversight committee and
the house Judiciary Committee this case
really isn't about Hunter it's about Joe
his father the big guy the one who
Hunter had to pay half his income to pop
form and pay for home repairs for pops
according to investigations by Grassley
Johnson Comer as well as bank records
shell corporations that they have
identified damning texts on Hunter's
laptop there is real evidence that the
president of the United States sold out
our country to foreign Nationals and you
the American people and all of us need
to get answers and the FBI needs to stop
covering for the president and keep stop
putting cinder blocks on the scales of
presidential elections but the first
lady of the United States Dr Jill Biden
he said it's shocking so many
Republicans support Donald Trump after
the quote indictment well given the
conduct of her son and her husband I
think she might want to sit this one out
I'll also like to introduce to Dr Jill
this document is called the U.S
Constitution where Americans are
innocent until they're proven guilty but
I guess the rule of law doesn't mean
much to the Biden say hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else